We're going to play a little game
called My First Time.
Oh...
It sounds very saucy and invasive.
The first movie you ever saw was?
The big one that
sticks out in my head is,
I remember,
going to see Grease.
-HOST: Yes.
-In the theater.
And I thought, "Well, that's it.
I need heels and tight pants."
(LAUGHING)
That's-- that was my take away.
That, like, the music,
the relationships.
I was like, "I have to get me some
tight pants and heels."
Me, too. I was like, to get a man,
I'm gonna have to change myself.
And that's-- that's why we're
here today. That's what we wanna
-...teach young women.
-HOST: Yeah.
The first R-rated movie
you ever saw?
I snuck downstairs while
my parents were watching Carrie.
We had doors that opened up,
so I hid behind a door
and I was just watching Carrie
through a--
through the crack in the door.
And I got real freaked out.
I was too scared
to go back upstairs,
so I just stayed there watching it.
And I watched the whole movie
and I just was quietly sobbing
behind the-- as my parents
were like, watching the movie.
The first movie that you related to
and had a real effect on you?
There something about,
Planes, Trains and Automobiles.
That I just remember feeling crazy
because I was laughing so hard
and then the next second
I was crying
and then I would laugh again.
I was like, "I feel crazy."
"Those aren't pillows..."
That whole movie is perfect.
It's perfect.
When was the first time
you realized you were funny?
My family is funny.
We sat around the...
the kitchen table every night
and had dinner together.
And it was always kind of like,
who could...
who-- and we were just
telling stories from the day,
but, like, I remember feeling
kind of, like, proud
if I told a story from my day
and, like, everybody laughed.
What was it like the first time
the director called action
on The Boss?
Kind of crazy because
I was producing it as well
and we kind of got sucked
into the vortex of...
of getting it, getting it started
and getting it going.
I always have a weird word or phrase
that gets me into, like,
the character's voice.
And I didn't have it.
And I thought-- I remember looking
at Ben and going,
"I don't-- I, I, I don't know
what she sounds like."
Then we did one take where
it finally felt like my...
I finally felt like I dropped
into it.
It's like, okay...
We're not gonna be--
It's gonna be okay.
Do you have a word now that you use?
Or did your character
just come to you?
On certain days,
Ben would make me do her laugh
and she goes, like, "Ha!"
Which later Kristen Bell was always
like, "You sound like Alf".
What was the first time that you
remember thinking, "I'm successful"?
Every time I wrap anything, I'm--
there's a little-- there's a...
probably seventy percent of me
that's like,
"Well... it was a good run.
I'll never work again."
HOST: (CHUCKLES)
I mean just to my core,
I always am like,
"Well, I'll-- I'll go back
to Illinois and...
probably, I don't know,
plant corn or something.
I just always think like,
"That's it."
The fact that we were like, "We
should write stuff and make movies."
Yeah--
At some point somebody
should be like, "You're nuts."
-And look where we are.
-I know!
HOST: It's amazing.
Thank you so much,
Melissa, for sharing
-your first time with me.
-Thank you.
-Yes.
-I appreciate it.
I'll never forget it.
HOST: (LAUGHS)